I'm governor jon corzine governor of
great state of New Jersey fiscal
responsibility is a very important
objective over the longer term right now
we have what I learned in econ 101 back
in my college days we're entered into a
liquidity trap where people aren't
spending money you can cantley you can
lead a horse to water but you can't make
a drink and right now consumers are not
spending money banks are not lending
money people don't have the confidence
to move forward and we need an outside
demand coming into economic life and I
think that can only be the federal
government so unfortunately even though
I believe on the long run we need to
have fiscal responsibility and balanced
budgets in the short run we need to
stimulate the economy we need for the
federal government to fill in for what
is not happening with the consumer what
is not happening by business spending
and that is only going to come from the
federal government we need a very
substantial stimulus coming into the
economy I'd say two to three percent of
GDP to put you in the 300 billion dollar
range might even be a little bit more to
try to fill in the space that is
occurring because our state governments
like New Jersey are consumers people on
Main Street and businesses are not
expending in the way that they would to
keep the economy growing